There we go. All right, so welcome to another Zoom call questions of the day that we have for the week really.
Are these photon versus proton radiation and so on. Let's just jump right into it and get to start it because these are questions that people have sent in. So if you do have a question for me,
or Michelle, please email that question it again and put zoom call in the header of your email so that we can make sure that we get it in.
So here was a question, please explain the difference between photon and proton radiation therapy, very confusing.
The biggest difference is there just one letter difference. Okay, no, nevermind. So the difference in photon beam and proton beam. So photon beam is regular radiation. So an x ray, if you want, got an x ray, that's a photon beam.
It's a photon beam tube that creates an x ray.
So photon radiation is far as therapy. They're basically be meeting you with constant x ray for a period of time and x ray is damaging to cells. So the positive of radiation is that it kills cells.
The negative of radiation is that it kills cells. So it's a catch 22 when you're using radiation to kill cancer cells because you can see you're going through tissue, the same thing is true with proton, but you're we're going to see that the little bit of a difference is not a huge difference.
When it first would proton beam radiation came out, which was, I don't know, I think what 10 years ago, maybe not quite that long.
It was touted as this latest and greatest radiation and it did less collateral damage.
And I think it is true. I think it does do less collateral damage. So if somebody has the choice to do, they're told to do radiation if they can do proton beam radiation.
I think it is better off. Now, that being said, that is more important if you're doing it through soft tissue, if you're doing it specifically on soft tissue.
So if you're doing it on the bone, let's say on your fever or, you know, on your tibia, something like that, I think it's less important to seek out a proton beam. Now, these are all over. I remember the first person that we were working with that it was a child that we are seeking proton beam radiation.
I was traveling for Minnesota down to Chicago because that was the only unit of the US at the time. So now they're all over most major cities have proton beam radiation as well.
Radiation are like x-rays, but a higher concentration and the difference is is that proton radiation, also called heavy ion radiation because it uses particles, a K protons to kill cells can be a little more specific and a little less damaging to collateral tissue.
That's the really the difference. So if you have the choice to do one of them, choose the proton beam radiation. If you're in a smaller area, smaller town and you only have the choice of photon radiation, well, that's your only choice.
If you're dealing with your radiating the spine or your radiating a bone, it's not, in my opinion, it's not quite as important to choose the proton beam radiation.
There's going to be there's going to be less collateral damage, you know, no matter what because it's easier to hit a bone and the bone is going to absorb more of the radiation, you're going to have less collateral damage what you're doing radiation on a bone anyhow.
So it's the soft tissue radiation that does the most collateral damage.
Okay, next question. What does it mean if my scan shows an increase in size of the tumor?
So we're talking about a scan showing an increased size of the tumor, you're usually talking about a CT scan, an MRI, a PET scan, or an ultrasound scan.
So if any of those show an increased size of the tumor, you have to, you have to, you have to look at the big picture, you have to take a step back and understand, oh, so I went from a 2.3 centimeter to a 2.5 centimeter.
Okay, well, there's, there's multiple factors that are involved. Number one, if you're killing a cancer, you are in effect, increasing the inflammation around the cancer because you are increasing the immune response.
So with an immune response comes an increase in that radiation or increase in that inflammation. That's just going to happen.
So that's, that's actually a good thing. But if I take a picture of it via CT scan or an MRI or a PET scan, it can show an increase highlight an increase in size because it's looking at the cancer is literally the inflammation around it is is that's what they're going to be measuring.
So it may not be a true increase in size. That's the first thing you have to look at. I always go back to a patient I had years ago, it was a child who they had done, there was a brain tumor that they had done chemotherapy.
And the child was doing so much better, they did another scan, other six month follow-up or three month follow-up, whatever it was. And it showed an increase in size and immediately the oncologist said, you need to start chemotherapy again, we have to get into this again.
And the mother was just really upset about it. And I said, let's get a second reading from a different radiologist. And we sent it down to another area of the cities and that radiologist said, no,
I think it is just the inflammation because the tumor is breaking up so that instantly the recommendation now when you're dealing with a child, you don't have a choice in the matter. So if that oncologist or the oncologist said, no, we're going to do chemotherapy, they would have been forced into chemotherapy.
And the reason why the mother was so upset is because the child did was not displayed any of the symptoms that they that she initially displayed with the with the initial tumor.
So how can this possibly be getting larger, she's doing great, she doesn't have any motor issues, motor dysfunction, how can this possibly be. Well, good thing we got that second reading, the oncologist conferred the radiologist conferred that it was probably just inflammation around the cancer.
So, nothing was done and the, you know, the patient did not have to go through anymore chemotherapy, which was a huge blessing.
So, number one, the tumor can be increase in size because there's more inflammation around the tumor because your body is actually killing the tumor.
Number two, the tumor can look increase in size because you're looking at a three dimensional back to actually a multi dimensional image multi dimensional tumor in a two dimensional picture.
So, that's very hard to measure it. The person is moving during the picture, the image, I mean, just think of this. I just put this geometric figure up here on the board.
And these are squares and rectangles and cylinders and cones and spheres, but the truth is the tumor has all sorts of different weird pieces on it. It's not perfectly round or perfectly never square.
So, are they measuring the same spot? Is it even, is it even mathematically possible to measure the same spot as the initial measurement was three months ago? No, it's not even mathematically possible to measure that.
So, when you're looking at a scan and comparing scan to scan, you're looking at, is there any gross differences? So, we went from a 2.3 centimeter tumor to a five centimeter tumor. Okay, there's an issue there. There's, there's some growth taking place.
We go from a 2.3 centimeter tumor to a 2.5 centimeter tumor. Okay, you got to take a step back and go, okay, well, maybe there's no growth taking place. Maybe there is. So, that's the third option. Maybe there is growth taking place. Maybe we need to change the course of treatment. Maybe we need to tweak something. Maybe we need to change something. Maybe we just need to keep doing what we're doing now.
And those are the questions that you have to ask yourself and to ask other professionals and get their advice. So, if my tumor doubled in size over the course of three months, that's probably not a good thing.
And that's probably not due to what we just talked about here. There is growth that's taking place.
But if I've been grow, if my tumor has been growing slowly, then, okay, that could be a bad thing. Maybe I need to tweak some things. Maybe this is as slow as it's, I'm going to get it to grow. Maybe it's going to grow to a certain size and decrease its blood supply and it's going to start dying from the inside out.
There's all sorts of possibilities that take place. Don't, don't, don't discount. Well, maybe I should do some chemo, but don't get scared into doing something that you're going to regret doing that you have done later. So, that's just my piece of advice. There's all sorts of possible answers.
When I look at a scan, an MRI, a CT scan, a PET scan, an ultrasound, and I see there's a change in size in my tumor. There's all sorts of possible reasons there. So, you have to, you have to differential diagnosis that out and not get scared into a course of treatment that you don't want to go down.
Next question, how do you do distance kinesiology? We get this all the time. And right now we're starting to do get cheek swabs from people to do distance kinesiology. We're including cheek swabs in our distance plans.
So, if you have got your distance folder and you have this plastic bag with different cheek swabs in there, that's what those are for to do distance kinesiology.
Now, this is what is applied kinesiology from the American College of Applied Kinesiology USA website. You can read that kinesiology is a system of bustle testing to really ask the body different questions that we've had people come to us that say, you know, I'm just not comfortable with kinesiology.
Is there another way to do the testing? Yeah, we could do other things we could use our experiential knowledge of dealing with cancer patients for the last 25 years and coming come up with a plan of attack, we could just solely depend upon genetics to come up with a plan of attack.
I've been practicing applied kinesiology for 35 years. Now that doesn't I do not say that to say that applied kinesiology is perfect by any stretch of the imagination. No test is perfect by any stretch of the imagination. There's always air in it. There's possible human air.
There's there's just that's just the nature of life. So I'm very comfortable in doing kinesiology. I personally trained Michelle in kinesiology and Ashley and added kinesiology but if people aren't comfortable with kinesiology, that's okay. We don't have to use it.
So, but if you're going to add, but if anybody, if anybody's been with me more for any length of time that we've had people when we used to have our Facebook page and we've always done this zoom call, people asked me to explain applied kinesiology.
You're going to get a blank stare because I'm not going to explain it. So I'm not going to try to explain applied kinesiology. So it's it's it is an art form. I used to try I used to have kinesiology courses that I taught to doctors and I quit doing it because I found that no matter how much you take an individual who wants to learn a technique.
There's an art to it. And it was frustrating to me that if they didn't have the touch, if they didn't have the intuition behind it and number and then most important thing if they didn't work coming from it from the right spiritual perspective, I didn't feel comfortable in teaching kinesiology.
I will admit that I will I will defend applied kinesiology, but I will not defend applied kinesiologists. There are a lot of applied kinesiologists, just like there are a lot of doctors out there that are using their craft the wrong way to to for whatever reason.
That's that's between them and God. So what we do applied kinesiology we literally pray over the swab or the patient when you're in our office and we ask that the answers come only from the Holy Spirit.
So if you're not a Christian and you think that is a bunch of who we then you might think the whole thing is a bunch of who we so you could ask to not just for us to to make our best educated decisions and how we're moving forward with your care.
We're totally comfortable doing that as well. So we want you to become comfortable with our decisions and and and how we're making recommendations as much as you need to become comfortable with it. So just ask for that.
So from but from this point on for people who are new to our clinic to do distance kinesiology to do a recheck we're getting a cheek swab from them or a saliva sample from them so that we could use that to pray over and to move forward with the muscle testing.
So that's that's all I'm going to say on that other question that people have is can patients receive more information on all the frequencies in their programs.
So again, for people who have been with us for any length of time some people are used to maybe going to a practitioner where they do the hand cradle testing for frequencies and then make a diagnosis off of that.
Now if you came into our office, we may have done the hand cradle testing on you to get more frequencies, but we never make a diagnosis off of that.
I do not believe that testing for frequencies is linked to a diagnosis. Let me explain that.
So when people say I want to know the frequencies that are in my programs, well, you can literally open any one of your programs. Here's a picture of Michael pneumonia Michael Plaza open and it's a 45 minute program.
Here's the dwell that's how much time it's on each frequency. Here's the frequencies right here.
These one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine frequencies in this program. Now your overnight program, you'd have to scroll through this.
And we asked that you don't play with this box on your right because you will literally you could change the program, especially if you saved it, you would change the program and it could totally mess up your program.
This is your program. This is what we write. So each night this piece of the of what's running down is your program and then this blue box down here is what exactly what frequency is running at any given second.
So if you hit run on this, it's counting down your program and it's running whatever frequency is showing up here. Now it's running actually two frequencies, a background frequency that's a pulse right and then the frequency that is the specific treatment frequency and you can see it right down here.
Now these are the frequencies. Now you'll notice that if you open up any of your programs, it will just say the frequencies. It just has the number. That is the frequencies. That's the hertz that it's running.
Now it doesn't say a specific disorder or disease or anything like that. Why because anybody who knows anything about frequencies doesn't believe that this one frequency is the frequency of pneumonia microplasma.
And that's why I don't like those cradle things, except we use it to gain more frequencies to utilize. I do not like it and I do not advocate using frequencies to, okay, you've got to hit on this frequency. That doesn't mean that you have that disease.
That means your body responded to that frequency and it might be beneficial to treat you with that frequency. It does not diagnose.
So you do not use a right machine to diagnose. I don't believe you use those hand cradle things to diagnose that can tell you, hey, that frequency could be good for you. But when we see practitioners go, oh, I had this because I did this hand cradle device thing. There's multiple different brands on the market.
I did the hand cradle device thing and my doctor said I have heavy metal toxicity of this thing or this thing or this thing. Well, that could point to those things possibilities. But when you start saying a person has that you're diagnosed seeing that person.
I just think that's bad medicine. I just think that's wrong. It's just it's just not true. There's there's multiple like in this case, there's there's whatever I counted nine frequencies that are commonly known for pneumonia microplasma.
Now, that's a specific issue. You look up strap and there's tons of frequencies. You look up different things. There's lots of frequencies in those sets because those are frequencies that practitioners have used over the course of time that have been beneficial for people with that disease.
They didn't use the frequencies to diagnose the disease. So when a patient goes, I really want to know the frequencies that are in my sets.
You can look at all the frequencies in your set. I don't know. I want to know what they're treating. We're not doing that because we don't do that. We don't diagnose via the frequencies nor are we saying that those frequencies are going to do anything specifically nor were we saying that those frequencies are treating a specific disease.
There's no frequencies. That's what they are. Now, they're helping your body respond to something. That's what we're hoping that they're going to do. But when you start, this is where practitioners and alternative practitioners really deserve to be shot down in a way, you know, you go, oh, you have to be careful doing what you're doing because the powers that be could shut you down.
I struggle with that because when practitioners are making claims that they should never be making. Okay, I don't think they should be practicing. I didn't think that's bad medicine. That's just bad care. So we are never going to give you. Can you just give us the frequencies and tell us what each one of them are.
No, don't ask us anymore because we're not getting them. If you want to look up frequencies, buy this book on Amazon. If you want the right handbook. It has a whole bunch of frequencies that these are I think she states it very well.
The author that these are just frequencies that are best that can help a person with this condition. So you can look them up yourself. But don't ask us about frequencies or what your hits were. If you came in the office and we scanned you.
We had people committed say, well, I want to know what all my hits are. You would not give it you those because I don't want you to to think that you have that disease because you don't that's just how your body responded at that time.
So I can't overemphasize that because that's what you know gets people like me in trouble is claims that other practitioners are making about the right that it's some panacea of every disease.
And if you just use the frequency of that disease, it kills it makes it disappear forever. Well, can that happen? It can. But you can't say that and you you can't even you can't even infer that. So you have to be really careful with that.
So I'm sorry I get on my soapbox there so much. Next question is please refer to our counters clinic daily blog resources on this page. I want to, you can see that I want to pull up our other website too.
Because we are being very careful that on our counters clinic page that we are not putting anything on vaccines.
So I'm going to pull up this page. I'll put this on I'll do a screenshot of this as well.
And I'll put this up on the slide right now.
So there you can see that so that we have another site looks almost the same.
But it's called my hope for lime and it's a site not just on live disease, but it's on it's on a bunch of different issues that are non cancer related.
The thing is that when we talk about on this site that our non cancer related is a vaccine injuries.
So on this site in the next couple days, I we don't have it up there yet, but on the blog post on this site, so it looks very similar to our cancer site, you go to the blog right here, just like on our cancer site, then it has some different blog articles, some of the same articles, but we pulled all the cancer articles off of this site.
And then the non cancer blogs and we have some different vaccine blogs on this site.
And you can go to the classroom here and our protocols here and in the classroom, you can go down to vaccine injury and look at the reason why I pointed you to this is because a lot of people on this call may have family members that are choosing to get the new vaccine that is out right now.
If you choose to do that, then a good thing to do is we're going to have on this blog and on this vaccine injury site, some information that will be helpful to help detox those things.
So if you or a loved one are thinking of getting that vaccine, I would suggest you go to this site, my hope for lime.com and go to our blog probably by tomorrow will have the blog post on detoxified for vaccine detoxified and a protocol for vaccine detoxified.
Also on this, if you go to the classroom, go to vaccine injury and scroll down, you'll see my article on a boarded fetal cells and vaccines and you'll see an article on the blog here that.
And Zimmerman are and here wrote on this COVID 19 vaccine that were being careful to not put any of that information on our colors clinic website because the chance of just us getting our website getting pulled by having any information on the vaccine.
But please utilize our blog. So a lot of questions that we get of people calling in are actually questions that are on the blog and sometimes I don't address a question that is emailed in because it's addressed much better and in more detail on the blog as well. So make sure you look at that.
When you go to the blog, you're going to see new posts. We are posting every day information research that we're finding articles new thoughts that we have on on the blog post. So make sure that you look at that.
If you've got a specific question that you can't find, there's that search bar on the blog, just type in that in and find it that will search the blog and the entire website.
We have over 450 blog posts at least, maybe 500 blog posts, that's 500 pages of just that and 300 some pages on the website.
So please look at that. And this also gives you information on how to go to videos here to and subscribe to our YouTube channel. We have I think 450 videos that you can follow as well.
Not just so much spend your time just researching or learning, but if you have specific questions, they are available on there.
I do have about 10 minutes or so, so I can open it up for questions. I think you can unmute yourself. So please do.
If you have questions, you can jump in. Let's limit it to try to limit to one question per person if we could.